good morning everybody and welcome to
this meeting of mid-suffolk district
council cabinet
i'm councillor susie morley leader of
mid-suffolk district council and i'm
chairing this meeting
today may i remind you of some domestic
arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and in the communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face
covering at all times unless you're
sitting down or if you're exempt from
doing so and that you use the hand
sanitizer and wipes provided
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
finally we were using e-voting for this
meeting on the modern.gov app so please
could all members make sure they are
logged in and ready to use the app
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully
excluded now going to move to the agenda
please
item one apologies for absence
yes chair good morning we have received
apologies from councillor gould and also
the overview and scrutiny chair
counselor welling
and the assistant director for planning
and building control
thank you very much
item two is to receive declarations of
pecuniary and non-pecuniary interest by
members
are there any to declare
no
item three
mca
21 38
to confirm that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 7th of february 2022
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
no can i have a proposal please
counselor heading under secondary
council flatman
uh governance officer
now conduct the vote thank you
yes yeah thank you the vote is now in
progress
counselor whitehead
have you voted
thank you chair that is um eight votes
for
that's unanimous
thank you very much
and
item four to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
none received
item five questions by councillors
none received
thank you item six matters referred by
the overview and scrutiny or the joint
audit and standards committees
there are no matters referred to
item seven is the forthcoming decisions
list
does anybody have any comments
thank you very much item eight
mca
21
39
is the general fund financial monitoring
report for quarter three 2021 to 22
and i'm going to invite the cabinet
member for finance to introduce this
report
thank you madam chairman um
i'd like to say a few words by
introduction to this report
in this report we're forecasting the
anticipated outcome for the year 2122
based on nine months of actual financial
data to the end of december which is
then extrapolated forward when combined
with a three-month forecast for quarter
four
so as the report shows the latest
forecast is for a 1.16 million surplus
for the year
at the time of the budget debate in full
council on the 24th of february
i had just received the site of this
draft report and the forecast it
contained
and it was this that gave me the
confidence to accept the opposition
amendment as a significant amount of
additional expenditure to top slice onto
our own emerging plans for next year's
budget surplus
i was pleased to see that gained
universal support of full council but i
am now concerned to see press reports
suggesting for the project i quote
it is hoped it would be up and running
within a few months
i wouldn't want anyone to underestimate
the amount of work that now needs to be
done by officers to bring a full report
on full business and social value case
to cabinet in due course
and of course that would include such
things as vehicle selection driver
recruitment timetabling fares
sighting of bus stops along with a
myriad of other issues to be determined
so i've digressed from the main purpose
which is to introduce this monitoring
report i do think it's important to set
out or perhaps reset
expectations on the electric bus project
at its embryonic stage
however now turning back to this report
appendix a sets out the anticipated
detailed revenue variances for this year
2122 with explanations and comment
we report again on the staff vacancy
position
as i know this is an area of concern to
all members
the savings are being reported across
most areas of the organization and the
table in paragraph 6.7 shows current fte
vacancies against budgeted fte headcount
the main drives of the increased
forecast surplus from that anticipated
when we looked at quarter two position
are
further staff savings 221 000
additional planning fee income 159
the leisure sports strategy carried
forward of a hundred thousand
changes arising from land charge income
of 90 000
an od training cost of 61 000
and a reduction in minimum revenue
provision for 75
000.
now in addition to the usual appendices
um you'll see there's a new appendix d
in this appendix we'll be reporting on
expenditure on the many individual
initiatives that make up the 5.138
million of cabinet approved projects
from the 2122 budget
243 000 is expected to have been spent
by this year-end with many of these
projects
being many of these products being spent
and delivered their benefits during the
next year 22-23
appendix e sets out our general fund
earmarked reserves and the movements on
those reserves during the year
but last but not least is the appendix f
which gives details of our cabinet sorry
our capitals program for 2122
including anticipated carryfors at the
year end
there are 27 projects itemized in this
capital project we anticipate that nine
10.494 million will have been spent
during the year excluding still spend
and grant supported public sector
decarbonisation
and that leaves 20.443 million of carry
forward the largest component of which
is the gateway 14 infrastructure which
should
commence around this year-end
the only other item to bring to members
attention is paragraph 3.3
which proposes the approval of revenue
carry forwards from 2122 to 2223
that this year be delegated as a section
151 officer
in consultation with myself
the reason for this new initiative
is that delaying the approval of these
items until the out turn report is
approved by cabinet in july
delays the incorporation of these items
into departmental 2223 budgets until
after one quarter of the new year has
already passed
so i'd now like to propose a
recommendation 3.3
along with asking cabinet to note the
forecaster's surplus position as set out
in recommendation 3.1
and to note the capital program has set
out in recommendation 3.2
so may also request another cabinet
member now to second those two
recommendations thank you
thank you do we have a seconder
councillor flatman thank you very much
do we have any questions from members
questions
councilman
thank you chair just trying to catch
your eye there
just a couple of questions um
the um the
table at 6.7 shows the the vacancies
with an average of 12 percent
and obviously some of those are quite a
bit higher
and then there may be reasons for that
and the one that sort of stood out to me
is housing is there any particular
concern around a 22
vacancy rate in
in housing that's my first question i've
got another one on the buses
as well
thank you councilmellon i mean i would
have thought um
any vacancy rate of that sort of level
must be a concern um of course it's a
question then how
how we get to get around that in terms
of i mean anecdotal evidence i've heard
is that um
this sort of vacancy level is not unique
to our council at all it's pretty much
across the public sector
but um if either
our ceo or
or
gavin all right ad for housing would
like just comment more and stick
particularly on housing have to hand
over
so i'll just say two things and then
i'll pass over to gavin if he wants to
add to it um yeah absolutely uh always a
concern in terms of vacancy rates and as
councilor whitehead has said
not unique to local government um but
clearly is of concern the only
additional fact i suppose specifically
in relation to housing is it's a large
service area for us now that in and of
itself may therefore make it a larger
concern that the vacancy rate is at that
level but what i mean by that is it
covers a lot of different areas so if
that was all in one component area so if
that was that kind of level but all in
homelessness then i would be more
concerned i suspect it spread out more
across the wider housing directorate but
i'll look to kevin fisk to see if
there's anything he wants to add in that
respect
thank you chair thank you arthur um in
response to the question from
councilmellon um we have more than 190
staff work in the housing directorate i
think he's the biggest director within
within the councils
what we do have are a number of
vacancies at any one time and that's
just natural in terms of uh movement
within our staffing base
as the chief executive uh pointed out
these will be spread across a variety of
different roles and responsibilities um
and as such we haven't got one team that
is facing a 22 percent uh shortfall in
in staffing numbers um we are actively
always recruiting to those roles and
subject to successful recruitment and
selection processes we would expect
those those appointments to be made
reasonably quickly
and also to just factor in that some of
those vacancies could actually be new
vacancies through some of the work that
we've been doing in terms of receiving
uh additional grant monies or through
the strategic priorities reserve that
you as members have set for example
we've just gone out of recruitment we've
just recruited a dedicated domestic
abuse advisor for the service so so
there are those examples as well
thank you do we have any other questions
on the papers
i've got one more if that's okay
um just to follow on the papers
yeah
thank you
the question is
just appreciating uh
councillors comments on the buses when
will when will that expenditure appear
in the
in the accounts in terms of the growth
and efficiency fund
this is a backwards-looking
report do you have a question on this
report
no fair enough thank you
does anybody wish to debate this item
okay
so the recommendations are that subject
to any further budget variations that
arise during the rest of the financial
year the surplus position of 1.160
million
referred to in section 6.6 and appendix
a of the report be noted
that the revised
2021-22 capital programme referred in
appendix e and section 6.17 be noted
and that the approval of carryforwards
from 2122
into 2223 be delegated to the section
151 officer
in consultation with the cabinet member
for finance
and i'm now going to ask the governance
officer to conduct the vote
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
that is eight votes for chair that's
your name
thank you very much
moving on to item nine this is mca
21-40 and is the housing revenue account
financial monitoring item for quarter
three
and i'm going to invite again the
cabinet member for finance to introduce
this report
thank you madam chairman
so i'm pleased now to give a brief
introduction to the housing revenue
account quarter three financial
monitoring report
again as for the general fund this is
based on nine months of actual numbers
december extrapolated forward using a
forecast for the final quarter to
produce the best estimate for the
year-end outcome
now in the quarter-one monitoring we
anticipate a deficit of 452 000 the time
the quarter 2 monitoring
97 deficit growing to 644 000 and now
with the benefit of nine months actual
and three months forecast the deficit on
the hra is anticipated to be 519 000
in all these forecasts the major element
of the deficit
has been driven by the level expenditure
in the building services area due to
covered lockdowns and restrictions
we've already discussed this during the
q1 and q2 monitoring cabinet
there really isn't much if anything to
add what's been said before
it's more a case of fine-tuning the
anticipated overspend with the benefit
of more actual data
as reporting the hra budget for the
upcoming year we've taken the learning
from this year to increase the building
services budget expenditure in 2223
now at present we're not forecasting any
changes for depreciation interest
payable and revenue contribution to
capital
i do have some concern that when
finalizing the outcome for the year
these numbers may change and if they do
we'll need to find some better
methodology to forecast them
however we must never lose sight of the
fact that the housing revenue account
must be viewed over its long-term
sustainability
and the 30-year business plan which will
be coming to full council in may and
then cabinet in early june
will tell us so much more about the hra
than this in-ear monitoring
turning to the capital programme we
spent 4.67 million on new bills and
acquisitions in the third quarter so we
have started to ramp up our capital
spend
anticipate a further 3.308 million on
new bills and acquisitions in the last
quarter of the year
that will leave a carry forward of 23.12
million in that category
plus 1.615 million on housing
maintenance
we are no longer anticipating any
further capital spend on hra ict
projects
we'll be reporting the actual out turn
for 2122 to cabinet in july so at this
point in time both revenue and capital
positions after noting only
i'd therefore like to move the
recommendations in paragraph three
that the financial information was
reported be noted
would ask for a second thank you
thank you councillor do i have a second
councillor hattingham
thank you yes i'm happy to second
thank you
do we have any questions from members
um does anybody wish to debate this item
okay
so the recommendations are that subject
to any further budget variations that
arise during the rest of the financial
year the adverse variance of 621 000
pounds referred to in section 6.5 of the
report be noted
and that the
2021-22 revised capital program referred
to in appendix a and section
6.14 denoted
so
governance officer you conduct the vote
please
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
that is eight votes four chair that's
unanimous
thank you
item 10
is mca
21
41 and is a quarter
3 performance
so this presentation is predominantly a
look back at the period covering october
to december of last year
and provides insight into the work which
is underway at this current time
i'd like to draw your attention to a
number of items which you will find
within the presentation however this is
not an exhaustive list of the progress
made against the council's strategic
this also highlights a number of
opportunities for collaborative working
with our partners
to enable the council to strive towards
achieving our objectives
so in summary under economy
we're working with suffolk county
council to develop an active travel
route within stone market to the town
centre
we held a successful local energy soak
showcase at wested in october with over
220 attendees
to date nine businesses have
participated in the
digital skills training program
the virtual high street continued to
grow with over 1600 vouchers being
downloaded over the christmas campaign
and the curiosity event for young people
was held in stone market focusing on
stem and cultural industries
receiving excellent feedback with young
people across the district attending
communities
we had the virtual connect and catch-up
sessions delivered for the integrated
neighborhood teams across the district
in partnership with both east suffolk
and ipswich borough council
a joint domestic abuse event was held at
mixing stone market with the integrated
neighborhood teams to promote awareness
and support of domestic abuse
and we worked alongside community action
suffolk supporting task and finish
groups on a new subject volunteering
strategy
on wellbeing the take-up for the
half-term family park cooking session
and christmas holiday events for
children young people has remained high
and these sessions have expanded to
include free spring free swimming arts
and crafts and football
and both our
our parks and active schools initiatives
have come to a close and evaluation of
these have been ongoing
on housing 62 of disabled facility
grants has been spent or committed to
date with 97 minor adaptation grants and
seven disabled facilities grants
approved to date
the number of average days to re-let
standard voids has increased however to
33 days for a variety of reasons
including hard to let properties
properties held to meet hospital
discharge as well as delays in building
services and contractors
chambers green our former hq site has
seen three new council homes completed
as well as five new market
homes and i'd also like to draw your
attention to the case study for
choice-based lettings which highlights
the work that has been undertaken in
reducing the average time to process
complete applications
on the customers quarter three saw a
reduction in both the abandon rate
which was reduced by eight percent and
waiting times from three minutes 30
seconds to two minutes 22 seconds
chatbots saw a marked increase in usage
increasing by 49
from quarter two
77 of customers rated our online forms
process at five out of five with an
increase in our customers choosing this
service
the number of stage 1 complaints
fell
by 25
compared to quarter 2
with a total of 172 being
received and we're working with
partners to deliver digital skills
support for our tenants to help reduce
the digital exclusion as well as working
with citizens advice in submitting a
joint bid for national lottery funding
to expand the digital hubs approach
on the health of the organization the
average number of days sickness per fte
for the year to date is 5.36 days and
this compares
to an average of 4.63 days west suffolk
and 4.52 days for east suffolk
a new 120 space community car park was
completed at woolpit health center a
timely project which enabled parking for
the nhs
vaccination drive
a new long lease arrangement is in place
for stone market football
club at green meadows
and planning consent was granted for
gateway 14 infrastructure works in the
business park
and i'd call for a seconder please
counselor
so we're not voting on this item this is
just for
noting if anybody has any questions
does anybody wish to debate
counselor
brewster
um if i if i may i'd like to just do
um a little bit on the quarter three
economy update
um
to share the considerable progress which
continues to be made in spite of the
number of teams still deployed on
providing government grants to our many
households
there are many businesses sorry
under a connected and sustainable theme
construction has continued on our new
cafe and visitor center for needham lake
with a public competition naming the new
space the duck and deet and teapot
building work also continues on the new
solar carport at the stomach at leisure
center
which will provide the facility
with a new local power source
importantly
we have significantly progressed our
flagship gateway 14 development
one of the number of tax sites under
freeport east which will unlock
innovation investment and more zero
carbon initiatives across the geography
in terms of active travel
infrastructure
we continue to move forward plans for a
new walking and cycling infrastructure
plan
have supported suffolk county council
plans for new cycle routes in stone
market which was subject to public
consultation and have worked with key
stakeholders in need and market to
establish a preferred option for making
the station fully accessible to
residents
and and users
under our innovative and creative theme
we have hosted the first ever local
energy showcase in suffolk
with over 200 delegates and a range of
national regional and local speakers
including a number of successful local
businesses
the two-day event saw local businesses
and community representatives learn more
about how to switch
to local forms of heat and power
and since the event we have been
providing ongoing support to a number of
areas who are keen to find out more
we saw a successful launch of the
cabinet's new council's new business
innovation support scheme
and launched a christmas campaign for
the virtual high street
which saw
excuse me sorry which saw over 1600
vouchers from local businesses
downloaded
finally as part of our successful and
skilled economic theme we held our first
carrierosity event for young people in
stone market
in spite of a spike in covered rates
towards the end of last year
we delivered this event over four days
with a range of industry experts giving
their time for free
and providing valuable insight into
careers in the music gaming and
financial industries
to name a few
the feedback from young people and their
parents has been fantastic
and we are currently putting together a
new program of events for later this
year
we also continue to administer the
successful welcome back fund enabling
more towns and parishes to carry out
events and make improvements to their
local areas
this is just a short summary of the
economy of the economy work
across this quarter
and there are many initiatives and
projects to mention which will continue
to make a real difference to the
businesses and places in our district
thank you madam
chair thank you councillor brewster
councillor richardson
thank you very much chair
i just wanted to build on some of the
detail that's in the well-being section
um of the quarter three report on page
69 for example the second bullet point
makes reference to the holiday
activities and food programme and the
fact that we were expecting um uptake to
be relatively low given that was in
particular the christmas period during
the middle of the omicron variant
but actually what we have found is that
there were 140 children that attended
those activities over the christmas
period which is a welcome number
relative to what we've been seeing thus
far
but more than that actually we've just
obviously had half term and we don't
have the data for that yet but looking
into the fourth quarter of the current
financial year i think we're going to
see an uptake absorb an increased uptake
in the number of um children that are
referred to that program and that are uh
participating in those activities but
looking ahead to the future now previous
this is a sort of a look back but one
thing that has happened which i think
will really impact on some of those
numbers is the department for education
has committed to three years worth of
funding for the the half programme which
is especially welcome for us because it
gives us that sort of longer term
certainty around planning and
organizing and publicizing some of these
these activities so for for context
the department funds the program for uh
the main school holidays we then fund it
for the for the half term but we are
responsible for delivering it all of the
program on behalf of the department for
education so that's a really um welcome
step that gives us that bit of bit of
certainty over the next few years and
it's certainly already beginning to
spread by word of mouth and is
simultaneously something we're looking
to build into our dedicated social
prescribing scheme so whilst those
numbers have been slightly lower than we
would have hoped over the christmas
period i think we're going to really
start to see those numbers increasing
over the over the next few months and
years thank you joe
thank you councillor richardson
councillor flatman
just to inform the cabinet and members
it is very clear from the number of
applications for various grants
including our locality grants
that our communities are really out
there and beginning to um
really um invest in their communities
and start all the clubs and leisure
facilities um sports etc
and the amount of grant applications
we're getting is just unbelievable at
the moment so it's really really good
news that our communities are out there
and enjoying their leisure time again
thank you
you councillor
does anybody else wish to
contribute to the debate
no so that report was just for noting
um moving on to item 11 mca
21 42
is the community infrastructure levy
expenditure program for march 2022
and we invite the cabinet member for
planning to introduce this
um
as you know
what we collect community infrastructure
levy
which we affectionately now sell
from um
developers for
uh
as as and when they build out uh
the
uh developments that they apply for
and we utilize this money
to
provide
infrastructure facilities for for
our communities the process involves the
twice yearly bid process on on the part
of any organization that would like to
bid into the fund
the bids take place during
may and october of each year
and um
um
her
keysight's an infrastructure team
ably led by uh professional lead
christine turlow who is sitting next to
me
um
processes
these bids
which involves an awful lot of very very
complicated
work first first thing they try to do is
make sure that there are no other
sources of funding
that would be applicable to a particular
piece of development
in order that we can conserve the fund
and apply it as uh efficiently as
possible
that work can take a long time and
it means that
some applications some bids
do take a time to come to maturity
um but you would be familiar that as
they do develop um we we deal with them
or those that are
relevant to the cabinet we
give them our approval or otherwise
at
a meeting such as this
and today
we have
four such bids to uh well three to prove
uh one to note and the one to note
is um because
it is uh
under the ten thousand pounds um level
which uh which we um
uh
we can
uh
approve under delegated powers as powers
delegated to
to the uh
to the assistant assistant director
of uh
uh planning
and um that is a a a development of uh
sorry um a bit at walt shameless willows
for the play park uh bid
which is for um
uh play equipment that's outdated
and someone's been un deemed unsafe
and has had to be removed
and during the local resident
consultation it was identified the
present play park had no facilities for
younger and preschool children
this project proposes to create a brand
new area suitable for young children and
toddlers
and the new equipment will use superior
items which will better serve the needs
of users be easier and cheaper to
maintain and have a greater
lifespan um
the bid
total cost of the project is twelve
thousand and uh twelve and a half
thousand and the
bid is for just over nine thousand
uh which represents seventy five percent
of the total project cost
[Music]
two other beds are
in stone market
um one is a stone market football and
social club
which is to deliver a new permanent
outside toilet block with male female
and disabled toilets
there's currently no separate permanent
toilet facility
that can be
assessed accessed on site and it is
understood that the provision of this
facility supports the elevation of the
football club club in in the
in the league
um
the consultation was carried out with
stone market town council together with
the warden district councillors
all supported this bid the exception of
one member who
confirmed that he was against the
proposals he felt the facility should
meet the standards of changing spaces
toilet
and that the baby changing facility
in the proposed building should not be
placed in the disabled toilet
these concerns were raised with the
applicant
and the design of the toilet blocks now
been amended to take the baby changing
facility out ensuring disabled users
have necessary space for the ease of use
and the baby changing facility will now
be placed in the permanent buildings on
site instead
[Music]
on this basis the proposal and the
amount of self-funding is acceptable
under the terms
of the sell expenditure framework
um and the sell bid represents uh the
seal bit of 25 000 pounds
represents 72 percent of the total
project costs
um the bill is the the bid is therefore
recommended to a cabinet for approval
the
second bid in
stone market is um
stone market crack wood allotments um
this is a project
this project
seeks to support the museum of east
anglian life
to deliver improvements to the current
facilities at crackwood and the
allotments
this will in turn present several short
and long term opportunities for benefits
to the community
visual immunity and biodiversity
a hundred year lease for the use of this
area is currently being drawn up for
agreement and is awaiting signature
these proposals will provide a better
space for food going as well as creating
a new community immunity for coombs ford
involving local people
currently there are issues with security
on the site and the existing boundaries
also unattractive
the project will both address these
issues and deliver clear community socio
and economic benefits together with
improvements to visual immunity and
biodiversity
total cost of this project is a hundred
and fifteen thousand eight hundred
pounds
uh and the sale bed is for seventy five
thousand pounds which represents sixty
five percent of the total project costs
this is within our threshold limits of
75 000 pounds and 75 percent of the cost
of the project
and as such the sell bid complies with
the terms of the expenditure framework
uh i
therefore recommend this for uh uh to
the cabinet for uh approval subject
completion of the lease
uh
and the final
bit today is at bottasdale record
recreation grants for 75 000 pounds
to regenerate the bottlesdale recreation
ground so that it can provide facilities
and ensure that everyone can benefit
from this open space for health and
well-being
it the self-funding will provide a wide
range of play equipment suitable for
different ages of children
and the overall project which is taking
place at the recreation ground will
provide health and fitness areas
accessible routes ecological and
biodiversity improvements and disability
parking
total cost of the project is 169 000
pounds and the syllabus for seventy five
thousand which represents forty four
percent of the total project cost
um i'd therefore recommend this uh
bid for approval by cabinet as well
uh and it just remains really for me to
thank um
christine and her team
um for the
really remarkable work which they do
carry out in looking at every last
little detail
of these bids
and
discussing them with all
[Music]
all the people that are likely to be
involved
uh including some of the
eventual recipients of the benefits
and so i do compliment her and her team
on on
the work that they do thank you
thank you councillor do we have a
secondary please counselor brewster
do we have any questions from members
counselor whitehead
it's not a question on the pacific
projects as such but there's there's
four projects here which total 184
thousand
and it seems the available funds have
got 2.8 million in one fund 5.9 in
another 2.7 another i'm just concerned
as to whether
oh well i asked a question where there's
a council we're concerned that we're
getting bids in on a timely basis and
enough bids and enough people sort of
realizes that money is there to be had
i could
christine to feel that question please
she's come all this way for nothing
otherwise
thank you yes the spend is relatively
small today given the size of the funds
that we do have but we are working on
a number of significant projects uh
which are not before you to consider
today but which are developing projects
coming forward
projects do take a long time to develop
either working through
issues with infrastructure providers or
indeed their their own processes before
we get to bring them towards you but
there are
a large number of projects which are
being delivered
well being developed and will be brought
forward for you to consider in the
future
thank you
got a proposal and
a second
does anybody wish to debate cancer
brewster
yeah
does anybody wish to
debate i think these are all
really worthy causes
um so the recommendations are
in 3.1 of your papers
so
um
i'm going to ask the government's
officer to conduct the vote thank you
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
chair that is eight votes four and uh we
that's unanimous
thank you very much
item 12
mca
21-43
is the climate change and biodiversity
annual report for 2021-22
and i'm going to invite the cabinet
member of the environment to introduce
this report
one moment um one moment canceller we
will get you
i'll move
thank you very much um
apologize
for that um
let's start
[Music]
i'm very pleased to be introducing this
um
annual environment report today
i think it's it's the first annual
report
and the report will continue from here
on to be produced annually
it sets out the significant achievements
that the district has made over the past
year or actually years in this case
both to reduce its carbon emissions and
ensure that mid-suffolk is prepared for
the impacts of climate change
is very broad in scope as well as
climate change the report includes
biodiversity
transport
and waste and other areas which are
identified from our biodiversity and
climate change action plans
i'm just going to say a quick
mention
regarding and a couple of of the things
that i hope everyone will note from the
report
um regarding climate change
i would like to mention the link to the
greenhouse gas inventory which was
recently completed now that has been
completed
actually since 2018
but i think this time
it's um its importance
um has
you know can just cannot be
underestimated as we track our
trajectory to net zero by 2030 because
the
greenhouse gas inventory shows us
where
um where the low-hanging fruit is which
i think we're starting to tackle in
terms of
climate change and also where the real
challenges are as we
pick the low-hanging fruit so to speak
and get into the more challenging areas
of reducing our carbon footprint as a
district
regarding biodiversity
i would like also to mention i know i've
mentioned it before the work done by
suffolk wildlife trust including its
wildlife network map
this autumn
and also very recently tree economics
has completed its first draft of a tree
canopy survey
and this information
gives us the tools we need to take
forward our commitments to biodiversity
net gain
as well as devaluing and conserving
wildlife and open space i would urge you
to read the report
it contains an ambitious
[Music]
ambitious targets and a lot of detail
which is the result of several years of
focused effort in cross-party working
of action planning and preparation and
motions to counsel all of which have
been valuable and which are only the
beginning of the journey towards more
sustainable governance
i look forward to working with my
district colleagues stakeholders other
local authorities and all interested
parties to ensure
we achieve the objectives which we've
set for ourselves
thank you
thank you councillor do i have a
secondary
councillor flatman
thank you
do we have any questions
thank you chair um
yes
paragraph 8.3 of the report which is on
page four
um
of the cabinet report talks about the
policy and legal risks
um and
does she agree with me that um alongside
the two
policy categories mentioned there
there's a third one which seems to be
missing which is
the idea of sequestering carbon
for example in using timber for building
[Music]
sequestering carbon in timber for
building
[Music]
that's a complicated one that i wouldn't
really expect to be included in this
report but
what i'm assuming your meaning is
using
native
wood
to build with can i just confirm that's
what you mean
well i think any any carbon which is
locked up in timber
for decades or hundreds of years it
obviously sort of contributes to our
bringing down carbon in the atmosphere
i'm happy to take your question outside
of this meeting because i'm not
absolutely clear on exactly what it is
you're asking thank you
yes thank you we'll ask officers to
investigate that
i think i think um
councilman if you can put your question
to me then then i will you know with the
help of officers respond thank you
thank you
does anybody wish to debate this item
okay so the recommendation is that the
contents of the report be noted
and that we produce this climate change
and biodiversity report annually
uh going forward
so
please could you conduct the vote
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
chair that is eight votes for that's
unanimous
thank you
item 13
mca
21 44
is the call in from overview and
scrutiny committee on the 13th of
january 2022
invite the cabinet member of the
environment to introduce this report
yes thank you
this
report addresses the um
the calling of
the
statutory taxing private hire vehicle
strategy
that took place in january
um i just
would like to um
to comment i mean this what this report
does is it um takes forward the
recommendations from calling and
scrutiny and
addresses the concerns but at the same
time enables the strategy itself
to go forward
[Music]
the taxi and private hire policy call-in
has however in my opinion
attempted to use an inappropriate
vehicle
to promote
the low-carbon transition agenda
the purpose of the taxi and private hire
strategy is
from here this is from the dft
[Music]
to
provide
consistency in the licensing system
and reduce the any risk of harm posed to
children vulnerable
vulnerable passengers in fact any
passenger
from traveling in a taxi or a private
hire vehicle
the dft
takes these responsibilities very
seriously
and here i'm just quoting from dft given
that the standards have been set
directly to address the safeguarding of
the public and the potential impact of
failings
the importance of thoroughly considering
these standards cannot be overstated it
is not a question of box ticking the
standards must be considered rigorously
with an open mind that is what the taxi
the primary objective the taxing
licensing
higher policy is
however the result of the call-in
was to delay implement implementation of
the statutory program
which was to have been in place
locally by the 31st of january and it
has caused significant additional work
for our officers
as well as
potentially
opening up the taxing private higher
vehicle trade to being out of compliance
with the new standards which the dft
mandated
we've done our best to remedy this
situation
and the result resolution this is before
us today
rightly distinguishes between the
requirements of the taxi and public hire
trade to comply with the department for
transport standards
and the district council's climate
change objectives
the the report sets out a reasonable way
for us to support the trade
in the desired transition
to cleaner fuel over time so i would
urge you to
to accept the recommendations in the
report today thank you
thank you councillor do i have a second
councillor brewster very happy to second
this one madam chair thank you does any
anybody have any questions
council miller
thank you chair um
the report mentions in a couple of
places about there being a significant
amount of work to be done to draw up the
proposals to support the transition
um could that be done uh on
through an officer and member panel
rather than just with officers alone
thank you chad
thank you um
the work will be done
with in consultation with the cabinet
member myself and um and officers um
if um
cass would like to come in in terms of i
know you're indicating you'd like to
comment cass thank you
thank you councillor yes just to add to
councillor fleming's answer there the
work will go through the licensing
committee as well so there'll be plenty
of chance for
both officers and councillors to comment
on the work before anything is finalized
thank you anybody wish to
engage in debate
council brewster
just a question uh
presumably the taxi firms themselves
will be consulted on
absolutely
yes absolutely
as as well as um
other parties such as the county council
and anyone involved in um
street works
we don't as you probably know have a an
official rank in the district so
we're not in a position to dictate where
or how eevee charging points can be put
in yet that is the would be the main
objective of um
bringing the desired transition of the
taxi trade into line with our
existing program to transition to
cleaner fuel within the district
thank you so the recommendation
is
in your papers 4.1
that the cabinet decision on the 6th of
december to adopt the new hackney
carriage and private hire
or sorry cancer richardson
apologies chair i just wanted to come in
very quickly on the debates um having
heard uh council fleming's introduction
and just wanted to
uh make the point that i think
we all should be honestly grateful both
to council fleming and to officers for
having come back so quickly with such a
pragmatic way forward i think the delay
was regrettable but i think it's it's
absolutely right and proper that we've
moved
forward so quickly on this to give that
assurance to um the industry that they
are in compliance with the new standards
from the dft so i think that's really
welcome thank you chair
thank you councillor richardson
so the recommendation is that the
cabinet decision on 6th of december 2021
to adopt the new hackney carriage and
private hire vehicle licensing policy be
confirmed
and that the matters raised by the
overview and scrutiny committee
particularly in relation to electric
vehicles be referred to officers and the
licensing and regulatory committee for
further work before that aspect is
presented back to cabinet
can we now conduct the vote please
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
that is eight votes for chair that's
unanimous
thank you very much
item 14
mca
21
21-45
is the response to national grid
statutory consultation on the brantford
to twinsted overhead line project
calling
and i'm going to invite the cabinet
member for planning to
introduce the report
council burn
thank you
um
yes the the branford twinsted overhead
line project is
as as i think we we all know is a
nationally significant infrastructure
project
[Music]
and
as such it we are not required to uh we
are not called upon to determine it in
any way it's not a planning project that
we have
uh
any role in in deciding uh it is decided
uh at national government level
um
nonetheless we do have an opportunity to
input into
into the consultations that are held
around this particular project and one
such is is
on and
on the go at the moment
and it is a national grid
consultation
that we have
discussed at various meetings uh
briefings and members have had the
opportunity to input into it
as a result of which
we have
put together
a response which you can see
in the
at the back of this particular report
and it does contain a lot of the
concerns and comments that have been
expressed by members
and when i say members i mean
members not only of mid-south but of
baba district council as well
because
safar's mid-suffolk is concerned as
although this um
this overhead line project does start at
brantford
it doesn't last in mid-suffolk for very
long before it moves across the border
into baba
and therefore it's of much greater
concern to babel district council that
just a mid-suffolk district council
nonetheless uh we are entitled as a
cabinet and should debate the matter
formally as you can see at the uh
the purpose of our report spelled out in
in uh paragraph one
um because the project is perceived to
be controversial
however the controversy is more that
more in in baba than it is in in mid
suffolk because
um the
the root that is followed by this
particular overhead line
[Music]
and it is described as an overhead line
but in fact the route crosses uh some of
baber's aomb
areas and is undergrounded is to be
undergrounded at those points
undergrounding is not without its
disadvantages even so and there will be
pretty much permanent scars on the
landscape as a result of this
however
that's what we've been asked to do so if
there are any um concerns
um
now is the time to
discuss them and
express them
and we can incorporate those in the end
response
i think that's enough
of a starter
over to you
thank you councillor byrne do we have a
second
council richards
have a second thank you chair
thank you um okay members i'm not going
to be taking any questions on this item
today as unfortunately due to sickness
we don't have any of our technical
officers
present to be able to answer them but
members have or all members have been
briefed fully on this
if anybody has any outstanding questions
or queries then they should direct
an email to councillor byrne and to the
assistant director for planning
who will be delegated to approve the
final response before it's sent off to
national grid
so does anybody have any
wish to engage in any debate on this
item councillor richardson
thank you chair i thought i'd make a
brief comment as the the report does ask
us to debate the matter but as
councillor burn rightly said in his
introduction um the most contentious
aspects of this are within baby district
council rather than mid suffolk so in my
contribution to the debate i'll simply
say the contents of the reporter duly
dated thank you chair
thank you
so the recommendation is that we respond
to the consultation
and that the assistant director for
planning and building control
in collaboration collaboration
with both the cabinet members for
planning
consider any proposed amendments to the
suggested response
that's been itemized and be authorised
to make amendments before submitting a
response to the government
if you could now conduct the vote please
thank you
you jen
me
members the vote is now in progress
chair that is eight votes for and that's
unanimous
thank you very much everybody so
the meeting is now formally closed the
date and time
you